bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour un nouveau numéro de c'est normand
nous sommes à granville dans la manche
en ces fêtes de fin d'année qui
approchent vous allez découvrir les
coulisses d'un des plus grands maîtres
chocolatiers français cédric hiver il
vient de remporter la médaille d'or au
concours international du chocolat de la
fin du mois de novembre à noël plus de
cinq tonnes de chocolat sont fabriqués
dans cet atelier du maître chocolatier
cédric hiver
l'enrobeuse va pas arrêter du tout la
semaine jusque
pendant les fêtes de fin d'année
représentent un tiers du chiffre
d'affaires annuel contraste raté c'est
deux mois de travail
mouche sur le mois de décembre six
personnes supplémentaires embauchées
pour préparer les périodes des fêtes
indispensable pour cette chocolaterie
artisanale 90% des tâches sont réalisées
à la main
[Musique]
à
on n'est pas envie de le goûter on goûte
quelques-uns mais sa seule passion et au
la force
en fait tu vois aussi gourmand pour
courage messieurs la qualité a un coût
ce travail manuel et en équipe se
répercute sur le prix de vente pour un
ballotin de 250 grammes comptait 21
euros les consommateurs seront pas de
tout repos mais on a un poste de
main d'oeuvre qui est très important
parce que beaucoup de minutie beaucoup
de patience et beaucoup de temps à
fabriquer le chocolat pour ses chocolats
traditionnels cédric hiver a remporté la
médaille d'or et deux coups de coeur du
jury au concours international du salon
du chocolat de paris
à ses côtés dans la liste du palmarès
des références comme la maison lenôtre
une grande satisfaction partagée avec
ses employés plus fier du temps du sua
parce que c'est des années des années de
travail de rigueur et je pense que
monsieur vers mérite amplement cette
récompense
moi je suis arrivé ici j'ai juste eu mon
bac et j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
monsieur et bergson donne ma chance
senghor bus une motivation
une distinction décernée aussi pour
l'innovation comme cette nouvelle
ganache au thé vert et pamplemousse rose
inventé par cédric hiver commercialisé
pour la première fois en ce mois de
décembre
c'est important j'imagine de créer sans
cesse de nouveaux chocolats à tous les
ans on crée de nouveaux nouveau parfum
c'est important pour la clientèle qui
est demandeur et pour nous aussi ça nous
évite de rentrer dans une routine avant
la vente
les chocolats sont conditionnés dans ses
ballotins plus de 5000 sont préparés
pour noël puis ils sont distribués dans
les trois magasins
la boutique historique la marquise de
presles au coeur de granville cédric
hiver vient de fêter ses 40 ans la
chocolaterie ses 70 printemps les
perpétue l'héritage de son père et de
son grand-père
j'ai toujours voulu faire ce métier là
j'ai été élevé dans une marmite en
chocolat pratiquement tout gagné et j'ai
toujours été passionné par ce qui est
hélas naturel que je reprends la suite
de l'entreprise
une fierté une satisfaction de devra
l'entreprise continue à être assez
velopper la croissance se poursuit pour
la chocolaterie avec ouverture dans le
centre ville de caen de ce nouveau
magasin depuis le mois d'octobre un
investissement de 500 mille euros
et avant de nous quitter de célébrer
noël cette phrase d'un dessinateur
américain john tullius cette phrase
inscrite ici dans le magasin hiver à
granville 9 personnes sur 10 m le
chocolat la 10e manche à méditer
je vous souhaite d'excellentes fêtes de
fin d'année sur france 3 et à très
bientôt pour un prochain c'est normand